[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité
chassez les œufs de Pâques au lieu des
animaux c'est possible dans les Vosges
dans une commune du département la
chasse est désormais proscrite le
dimanche après-midi une décision prise
par la mairie en accord avec les
principaux concernés nous expliquera
Vosges TV dès le début de ce journal
une vie professionnelle après l'armée
nous nous intéresserons aussi dans cette
édition à la reconversion des militaires
après leur carrière un profil vous allez
le voir très recherché par les
entreprises
connues de tous les Français grâce au
cinéma le Camping des Flots Bleus renaît
de ses cendres le site tarent ouvert ses
portes cette semaine après les incendies
ravageurs de l'été dernier et plusieurs
mois de travaux au Pilat une réouverture
à laquelle a assisté TV7 la chaîne du
groupe sud-ouest
une pharmacie à 1 euro TVR à Rennes nous
dévoilera peut-être la meilleure affaire
immobilière du pays un prix symbolique
et symptomatique des difficultés à
trouver des repreneurs pour les
commerçants dans les zones rurales
mais en débute donc ce journal avec une
première en France qui ravira c'est sûr
les promeneurs Dominico à
Saint-Dié-des-Vosges les dimanches
après-midi sont désormais interdits à la
pratique de la chasse une mesure décidée
par le conseil municipal en concertation
avec les chasseurs locaux une décision
qui permet en quelque sorte de mieux
partager les forêts reportages et
précision de Marie Daniel rogovitz et de
Nicolas bredart pour Vosges télévision
promenons-nous dans les bois quand le
chasseur n'y est plus cette phrase
résume avec un brin d'humour la décision
prise à l'unanimité par le conseil
municipal de Saint-Dié-des-Vosges
interdire la chasse les dimanches
après-midi des 13 heures dans deux des
quatre massifs qui entourent la commune
cette initiative du maire s'est faite en
amont en accord avec les chasseurs on a
voulu rendre une partie des massifs des
audaciens au déodacien le dimanche
après-midi j'ai bien passé et ça s'est
fait main dans la main on se veut une
ville verte une ville touristique
accueillante par la forêt également et
si la forêt interdite aux gens que c'est
Paul c'est pas le but du jeu car à
Saint-Dié depuis 2003 la chatte était
aussi interdite les mercredis cette
fois-ci dans les quatre forêts
communales cette nouvelle interdiction
les dimanches après-midi a pris effet
depuis le 1er avril pour la prochaine
saison de chasse ajoutez les dimanches
après-midi par ailleurs ce n'était pas
vraiment gênant pour les principaux
intéressés les trois corps du temps
c'est vrai que bon on termine de bonheur
maintenant c'est plus comme avant mais
bon c'est vrai que on arrive des fois
terminé à 15h lors de ce reportage
matinal les quelques marcheurs avaient
étés
cœurs on va où devant Dieu en leur
demandant si on peut aller prendre tel
ou telle direction donc la plupart du
temps ça se passe quand même
relativement bien et chez chasseur
ils sont devenus très fréquentables bon
même avant moi je mange mon chien est
toujours en liberté et souvent je les
voyais me regarder d'un seul œil
maintenant non c'est interdiction de
chasser va principalement rassurer les
familles et les touristes lors des
balades dominicales une décision de la
commune de Saint-Dié qui reste tout de
même assez rare en France
et une autre bonne idée justement la
location de voiture entre particuliers
une opération aussi pratique qui
économique pour le loueur comme pour
l'emprunteur les plateformes proposant
ce service se développent dans un
contexte économique compliqué pour le
portefeuille de chacun un sujet de
Jérôme Aubron pour ohé TV la chaîne de
la Voix du Nord et du Courrier Picard
bonjour ça va Laurent
Christelle vient d'atterrir à l'aéroport
de Beauvais venu du sud de la France
elle découvre pour la première fois le
véhicule qu'elle conduira pour le reste
de la semaine ils se sont contactés via
une plateforme de location de véhicules
en ligne ici tout est dématérialisé
propriétaire et locataires entretent
même l'intégralité de leurs données
directement sur leur smartphone permis
de conduire carte grise jusqu'à l'état
des lieux en quelques clics tout est
consigné tu as fait le constat extérieur
on a noté les clients métrages comme
quoi qu'il y avait plein de tout ça
comme ça la locataire c'est que tout
était enrhul et comme ça on signe tous
les deux en même temps pratique et
économique Laurent loue cette voiture
deux fois par mois une voiture de 20 ans
qu'il avait d'abord pensé mettre en
vente quand je me suis renseigné chez un
concessionnaire il me l'a reconnaît 500
000 euros et là en sachant qu'en huit
mois je me suis déjà fait 800 euros un
modèle d'économie collaborative
intéressant pour Christelle pour 6 jours
de location et la possibilité de
parcourir 300 km elle déboursera 85
euros la différence entre cette
plateforme et une société ça vous
reviendra minimum j'ai à 50 euros et
après jusqu'à facilement 100 euros en
plus le succès de la location de
véhicules entre particuliers n'est plus
à faire si bien que les plateformes se
sont multipliées sur le web et la
période d'inflation pourrait bien doper
un peu plus ce marché alternatif
et en cette période d'inflation chaque
rencontre à l'heure de faire les courses
pour soutenir les ménages les plus
fragiles la municipalité de l'Orient a
décidé d'élargir les critères d'accès à
son épicerie solidaire un changement
bienvenue pour faire les courses à
moindre frais à un sujet de Karine
Chevrollier pour TBO la chaîne du groupe
telegram
dans la réserve de l'épicerie solidaire
de Lorient les mains des bénévoles
s'activent à son ouverture il y a 8 ans
environ 600 foyers étaient inscrits on
en compte désormais 738
de plus en plus ce chiffre augmente
d'année en année mais la Ville estime
qu'environ 25 à 30% de personnes ne
bénéficient pas d'aide auxquelles elle
pourrait être éligibles même quand on
gagne le SMIC ou un peu plus on peut se
retrouver avec des factures d'énergie
très importantes on peut se retrouver
avec une accumulation de crédit qui
évolue aussi au rythme de l'inflation on
peut se retrouver des accidents de la
vie et donc des difficultés financières
importantes pour s'ouvrir à plus de
foyers la ville fait notamment évoluer
le calcul du reste à vivre au quotidien
ce qu'il reste à un ménage après le
paiement de tous les frais fixes la
dernière trancheuse barème est à 14,50 €
et puis on prend en compte désormais
aussi la constitution des foyers
c'est-à-dire si on a foyer de plus de
deux personnes on augmente encore de 10
euros l'accès entre autres à l'épicerie
mais franchir la porte d'un centre
d'action sociale n'est pas toujours
évident
c'est compliqué et c'est pour ça qu'on a
souhaité que ne pas faire de colis
alimentaire mais bien d'avoir une
épicerie et puis notre objectif il est
de voir si la personne elle a bien fait
appel à tous ses droits légaux les
produits alimentaires sont ici vendus à
hauteur de 10% du coût initial 30% pour
ce d'hygiène et ces derniers manquent la
Ville lance donc une campagne de dons à
déposé en mairie du 3 au 13 avril
prochain
ségolène Royal était l'invité jeudi
matin de l'émission Face au territoire
sur TV5 Monde l'ancienne ministre de
l'Environnement et ancienne candidate à
la présidentielle regardez cet extrait
de l'émission
est-ce que vous l'avez envoyé à
Elisabeth non j'ai pas envoyé je vais
vous passer un extrait d'Elizabeth borne
sur ce plateau à votre place même
c'était le février 2022 elle a été votre
directrice de cabinet je rappelle au
téléspectateurs on l'écoutait Isabelle
nord de la première ministre vous avez
des nouvelles de Ségolène Royal dont
vous avez dirigé le cabinet
je vais pas pouvoir vous donner une
nouvelle fois vous n'avez pas de
contacts donc je pense qu'on est pas
tout à fait d'accord sur beaucoup de
sujets pourquoi
plus de contact quand on a été si proche
c'était votre directrice de cabinet mais
moi je suis à sa disposition si elle
fait quelques conseils c'est pas moi qui
rompu les contacts on va lui faire
passer le canapés
la première ministre et vous c'est deux
caractères très forts
j'ai connu comme préfet de
Poitou-Charentes donc vous voyez donc je
correctement travailler avec elle et
quand j'étais nommé ministre elle m'a
appelé pour être mal directrice de
cabinet c'est elle qui vous inscrite
l'émission Face au territoire avec
Ségolène Royal est à voir où à revoir en
replay sur le site internet de TV5 Monde
et chez les partenaires de l'émission
Ouest-France Nice-Matin France anti 20
minutes la montagne et le magazine Le
Point allez tout à fait autre chose
maintenant dans ce journal d'une
carrière militaire à l'entreprise les
officiers de l'armée sont nombreux à
franchir le pas leur profil est souvent
très apprécié par le monde de
l'entreprise et pour mieux les épauler
dans leur projet le ministère des armées
vient de signer une convention avec des
raisons internationales d'entreprise le
forum francophone des affaires les
détails avec ce reportage de Christophe
Rigaud regardez
bonjour à toutes et à tous soyez les
bienvenus bonjour
après une carrière militaire beaucoup
d'officiers supérieurs trocent leur
galon pour des postes à responsabilité
tant de grandes entreprises cette
seconde carrière après l'armée est
encouragée par le ministère de la
Défense qui favorise les passerelles
avec la société civile et le monde de
l'entreprise donc c'est du
gagnant-gagnant gagnant pour les
entreprises qui évidemment interviennent
dans des secteurs ou sur des segments
qui sont très complexes et sur lesquels
il y a besoin de savoir faire et puis
gagnante dans le modèle des ressources
humaines pour nos armées aujourd'hui à
l'Hôtel de Brienne c'est le forum
francophone des affaires qui est venu
signer une convention avec la mission de
retour à la vie civile des officiers
généraux des militaires qui ont des
compétences particulières à mettre au
service des entreprises j'ai vu qu'elle
était la qualité la qualité pédagogique
d'éducation que les officiers généraux
ont et ensuite il faut le dire
l'engagement que de l'heure l'engagement
dans la langue française dans le Patriot
oui on a besoin des officiers généraux
et à tous les niveaux d'entreprises pas
simplement dans l'opérationnel donc
aussi ce qui est stratégique et les
exemples de poursuite de carrière
professionnelle réussie son nombreuses
j'ai en tête le général Baltique était
avec nous qui est directeur général de
la semarys à Rungis depuis 12 ans et qui
était un ancien directeur de l'école
militaire de haute montagne de l'armée
de terre qui était aussi officier
général lui-même j'ai mis à Rungis la
même énergie le même engagement que j'ai
mis que dans ma carrière militaire parce
que ce sont des métiers de passion
ces retours à la vie civile sont
largement accompagnés par le ministère
de la défense car un officier supérieur
peut être rappelé à tout moment par
l'armée en cas de guerre ou de crise
majeure
des forces armées au soldats du feu dans
cette édition prenons la direction de la
Moselle un département de plus en plus
confronté malgré sa situation
géographique au risque naturel comme les
feux de forêt dans la perspective de
l'été les pompiers départementaux
participent à des simulations d'incendie
en milieu naturel
jean-mylon pour Moselle TV a pu suivre
l'un de ses exercices regardez
alors qu'on soit bien tous d'accord il y
a deux routes importantes sur le
territoire de Beach à proximité du camp
militaire un barbecue sauvage a dégénéré
le feu est parti les premières équipes à
court pour le contenu on est arrivé en
primo intervenant avec deux engins de
1750000 litres et on a commencé à
attaquer un feu de végétaux où on a
demandé des renforts avec un groupe
d'intervention feu de forêt avec quatre
CCFM camion citerne forestier moyen de
4000 litres problème rapidement les
réservoirs d'eau se vides et de ce
serait sont vides donc on va faire le
nécessaire pour faire alimenter je vais
faire avec toi une reconnaissance pour
un point d'alimentation j'ai vu qu'il y
avait un point d'eau il faut donc
trouver un point d'aspiration proche et
accessible pour les véhicules on est en
train de pomper de l'eau grâce à notre
ce qu'on appelle une motopompe donc il
peut développer 2000 litres minutes sous
15 bars au total cette manœuvre implique
près 250 personnels et 25 engins dont un
poste de commandement sur le massif
forestier de Bitche c'est un beau
terrain d'exercice qui est également là
dans le secteur et apportant avec les
forces sécheresses annoncées dans les
futures années et pour s'y préparer au
mieux les sapeurs-pompiers travaillant
étroite collaboration avec l'Office
National des Forêts capables d'apporter
un réel soutien sur la connaissance du
terrain
là ça devient très résineux d'accord
donc ça veut dire que la propagation
sera plus forte ici que là en 2022 le 10
57 a réalisé plus de 1200 interventions
pour feu d'espace naturel dont 17 en
Moselle
voilà et vous le savez les feux de
forêts ont causé d'énormes des gars
l'été dernier un peu partout en France
des dizaines de milliers d'hectares
partis en fumée dans le Sud-Ouest
essentiellement et parmi les sites
impactés le très célèbre Camping des
Flots Bleus il accueille de nouveaux
vacanciers après 7 mois de fermeture
vous allez le voir une nouvelle saison
attendue pour ce lieu devenu célèbre
grâce au cinéma reportage sur place
d'Alix au Fourcade pour TV7 la chaîne du
groupe sud-ouest
ce touriste a voulu immortaliser le
moment la réouverture du Camping des
Flots Bleus ce lundi après 9 mois de
fermeture à l'entrée sont directeur est
encore dans les derniers potages à faire
on a quelques câbles à cirer mais sinon
non non sinon ça va les logements les
emplacements tout ça on est bon positif
Franck Couderc et pourtant l'année
dernière la quasi-totalité de son
camping est parti dans les flammes des
incendies ravage en notamment ses
nouvelles cabanes
qui avait été livré au 12 juillet on en
avait loué deux les gens étaient très
surpris de voir la qualité de l'ensemble
malheureusement
installer le 12 brûler le 18 mais pas en
subit le même sort mais il reste
quelques survivants
peut-être notre arbre symbole un symbole
qui touche aussi les occupants
historiques du camping comme ces
moniteurs de parentes qui entame leur
18e saison au flots
et en plus on est reconnaissant à tous
les stagiaires qui viennent nous voir
parce qu'on savait pas trop dans quelle
mesure ça allait pouvoir reprendre aussi
vite derrière le remplacement on se
heurte à une barrière avec une zone qui
reste en chantier une réouverture
partielle certes mais salvatrice pour
les six salariés du camping on a besoin
de tourner la page on a besoin après
avoir perdu notre boulot on a besoin de
le retrouver et donc c'était important
qu'on ouvre de façon normale des travaux
estimés à environ 8 millions d'euros que
Franck Couderc finance aujourd'hui sur
ses fonds propres comme les autres
campings impactés en attendant les
indemnités des assurances
voilà cet été encore la sécheresse
s'annonce sévère en France le manque
d'eau notamment pourraient se faire une
nouvelle fois pressant dans plusieurs
départements une inquiétude qui a
poussée un port des Pyrénées-Orientales
à mettre en fonction un nouvel
équipement un conteneur de
désalinisation grâce à ce prototype que
vous découvrez sur ces images de via
Occitanie l'eau de mer est transformée
en eau douce particularité de cette
installation l'énergie nécessaire au
processus est entièrement produite par
des panneaux solaires les précisions au
micro d'Alizée Marty et de Bary Isaac
regardez on règle d'une certaine façon
la question économique puisqu'on a un
modèle vertueux ou c'est des énergies
renouvelables qui permettent de dessaler
et donc avec un impact économique moins
important puisqu'on ne va pas utiliser
des hydrocarbures pour produire de l'eau
dessalée et puis c'est aussi une toute
petite unité
qui nous permet d'avoir un test grandeur
nature mais sans prendre des risques du
point de vue de la biodiversité
acheter une pharmacie pour 1 euro non
vous n'arrivez pas c'est bien le prix de
vente d'une officine non loin de Rennes
un montant pour le moins étonnant qui
doit permettre de séduire les repreneurs
à 68 ans l'actuel propriétaire aimerait
bien prendre sa retraite mais rien n'y
fait cela fait 5 ans désormais et qu'il
essaie de vendre sans succès sa
pharmacie un sujet de clair griot pour
TVR
oui pharmacie bonjour depuis quelques
jours le téléphone sonne davantage dans
cette pharmacie
à l'autre bout du fil une personne
intéressée pour acheter son officine
on peut pas absolument pas
à sa première cela fait 5 ans qu'il
tente en vain de vendre sa pharmacie
créer en 1988 d'abord 350 000 euros il
descend à 50000 puis à 1 euro symbolique
malgré cela aucune candidature sérieuse
c'est pas tout il y a pas que chez moi
pas travailler comme nous quoi il veut
travailler que trois jours et demi
quatre jours par semaine ça fait 36 ans
celui-là quoi
profiter ma retraite pourtant la
pharmacie est très rentable avec un
chiffre d'affaires annuel de 850 000 € à
ses côtés travail est un apprenti et une
préparatrice en pharmacie embauché il y
a 26 ans elle espère continuer à
travailler ici pour un repreneur c'est
vraiment une opportunité un travail de
lundi au vendredi
on c'est difficile de demander mieux on
a dit pas ça on a du monde on est quand
même trois aujourd'hui donc il y a quand
même du travail quoi sentiment partagé
par les clients dépités de perdre un
nouveau un commerce
le jour où la pharmacie s'arrête il va y
avoir des répercussions derrière faute
de repreneurs
définitivement le rideau de sa pharmacie
le 31 août la mairie de cette commune de
1200 habitants s'est engagé sur l'achat
des murs pour soulager financièrement un
éventuel acquéreur moyennant un loyer
raisonnable
intéressez vous le serez peut-être aussi
par le métier d'éclusier une profession
méconnue et qui embauche avec le retour
des beaux jours dans la Sarthe
collectivité et Pôle emploi se sont
associés pour faire découvrir ce métier
à des demandeurs d'emploi ces derniers
pourraient bien devenir les prochains
saisonniers en charge de faire passer
les bateaux sur les cours d'eau un
reportage de Florian Wozniak pour LM
télécharger
ce sont peut-être eux qui ouvriront la
porte des écluses la saison prochaine
tous inscrit au Pôle Emploi du Mans ils
sont plus d'une vingtaine à avoir
répondu présent à cette présentation du
métier d'éclusier c'est vrai que quand
j'ai vu cette annonce du Pôle Emploi là
j'ai dit ça moi je peux dire ça fait
titre et c'est un travail original parce
qu'on pense pas moi c'est un travail
auquel je pensais pas ce métier Annie
Claude le connaît sur le bout des doigts
puisqu'elle exerce depuis 26 ans elle
est la troisième génération d'éclusias
de sa famille et n'aurait changé de
profession pour rien au monde l'été de
avril à fin septembre on travaille 6
jours sur 7 de 9h le matin à 12h30 14h
19h donc ça peut freiner vous savez
quand on voit les contraintes et qu'on
voit les avantages tant que la balance
c'est des avantages un cadre de vie j'ai
le logement de fonction le département
de la Sarthe compte 16 écluses et chaque
année il recrute des saisonniers entre
le mois d'avril et 2 septembre pour s'en
occuper il faut savoir travailler de ses
mains il faut du brouillard il faut
avoir quand même malgré tout une forme
physique voilà pour manœuvrer les
ouvrages et puis effectivement il faut
être communicant il faut aller au devant
des gens il faut savoir parler de son
département voilà pour cet été l'équipe
d'éclusiers est déjà complète les
prochains gardiens du réseau fluvial
seront recrutés à partir du mois de
janvier de l'année prochaine
voilà ces jours-ci vous êtes nombreux
c'est sûr à célébrer Pâques un moment
aussi familial que gourmand chaque année
petits et grands se régale de chocolat
mais alors comment est préparé un bon
chocolat élément de réponse avec ce
reportage de TL7 chez un artisan
chocolatier où tout est fait maison un
sujet intéressant et appétissant bien
sûr
des œufs petits ou gros de la friture ou
encore des écureuils d'ici quelques
jours il viendront garnir vos jardins et
si vous avez décidé de les consommer en
circuit court c'est Anthony qui vous les
aura peut-être confectionné ce jeune
chocolatier achève plusieurs semaines
dédiées à Pâques et le secret c'est
d'abord le travail de la fève de cacao
on va effectuer une torréfaction qui va
durer entre 10 et 15 minutes et entre
100 et 130 degrés on va chauffer la fève
et c'est vraiment du coup effectuer ce
qu'on appelle la réaction de Maillard
c'est ce qui va nous permettre que les
arômes de la fève vont ressortir encore
plus un travail de patience car il faut
environ 48 heures entre la torréfaction
et l'emballage final entre les deux pas
moins de cinq étapes de la récupération
du Gruet de cacao à l'élaboration de la
recette forcément très gourmande donc on
va mettre
notre masse de cacao ou autrement dit
liqueur de cacao après on va venir
ajouter du sucre du beurre de cacao de
la lécithine de tournesol et une petite
pointe de vanille et on va laisser
tourner pendant 24 heures
place au moulage
pour faire remonter un petit peu toutes
les bulles d'air qu'on en Europe
et après on va mettre directement
refroidir au frigo paquet donc une
période essentielle pour cette
chocolaterie qui fait elle-même toutes
les étapes de fabrication de A à Z
allez ouvrons une page consacrée au
sport dans ce journal alors que se
tenait cette semaine partout en France
la semaine olympique est paralympique
dans le cadre des JO de Paris 2024 une
semaine pour encourager les plus jeunes
à pratiquer du sport en Martinique comme
vous le voyez sur ces images fournies
par nos confrères de vie à TV les
écoliers ont pu notamment participer à
différentes activités au programme des
Jeux Olympiques
chanceux ils ont pu également rencontrer
la nageuse médaillée coranie Balmy la
Martiniquaise avait remporté une
médaille de bronze à Londres en 2012 et
en ce début des vacances de Pâques il ne
vous reste plus que quelques jours pour
profiter du ski l'occasion de nous faire
découvrir le ski photo œil une pratique
vous allez le voir qui s'exerce en
tandem et qui reproduit toutes les
sensations classiques de la glisse
Laurent Pernet atteint de la maladie de
Charcot en a fait l'une de ses
occupations favorites une manière pour
lui de refuser le caractère incurable de
sa maladie Lucile délit pour Télé
Grenoble
on a connu des conditions meilleures et
ce jour-là ont grimace quand les pistes
de Chamrousse ramollissent Laurent lui
ne pouvait pas rêver mieux commençons
les sensations Laurent
le soleil la glisse le grand air oxygène
son mental Laurent Pernet
ski de temps et rien ne l’arête pas même
la sclérose latérale amyotrophique cette
maladie de Charcot qui paralyse
progressivement son corps depuis quatre
ans il combat la souffrance en lui
opposant le plaisir en mouvement c'est
pas parce que la mobilité réduite petit
à petit que on peut rien faire et on
peut continuer surtout de faire des
activités adaptées certes mais on peut
continuer de sortir en plein air il y a
des solutions qui existent mais elles
sont coûteuses le SF a investi 10000
euros pour ce fauteuil tandem monté sur
les skis pilotés par Morgan et qui
reproduit les sensations pour l'un comme
pour l'autre des skieurs le pilote
derrière va être sur des étriers qui
vont rentrer dans la neige pour pouvoir
freiner on va pouvoir venir s'incliner
comme ça et en fait ça va gérer
l'inclinaison des skis et une prise de
car c'est ce qui va nous permettre
finalement de tourner
on tourne en accélère et on ralentit la
progression de la maladie ce n'est pas
une vérité médicale mais Laurent en est
certain comme si l'adrénaline associée
au plaisir d'aller travailler chaque
matin dans son entreprise de distillerie
artisanal lui injecter un remède contre
la résignation le projet par exemple de
descendre les vallons de la mèche 9 mois
plus tard il s'y préparent déjà dans
l'espoir aussi de sensibiliser de
mobiliser les forces les fonds pour
accélérer la recherche l'espoir de
guérir qu'il ne lâchera jamais
allez projetons-nous au mois de juillet
pour terminer ce journal à moi qui vous
le savez signifie vacances d'été mais
aussi Tour de France la grande boucle
qui passera cette année par la Ville de
Limoges pour ça 8e étape un événement au
retombé économiques importantes pour
lequel se prépare déjà depuis plusieurs
mois la commune propose
direction des sports le dispositif
d'arrivée mais en complémentarité avec
la direction des ateliers avec la
communication c'est toute une équipe en
fait ville de Limoges qui se met en
place pour faire arriver pour faire en
sorte que les quatre kilomètres sur
Limoges se passent au mieux c'est un
chantier qui aura duré plusieurs mois
c'est un chantier qui a commencé en fait
début novembre on a commencé début
novembre pour une arrivée 8 juillet donc
ça fait 8 mois de travail à peu près et
il faudra encore patienter quelques
semaines avant le début de la 110e
édition du Tour de France le départ sera
donné à Bilbao en Espagne le 1er juillet
prochain voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition merci d'avoir suivi ce grand JT
des territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition on va voir
tous
[Musique]